molecular clouds are the birthplace of
stars and planets but how these
diaphanous fogs of gas collapse into
burning balls of hydrogen is not well
understood part of the problem is that
the exact shape and structure of the
clouds is hard to discern since we only
see them from one point of view
researchers have now found a new way to
reveal such structures by finding a
molecular cloud that oscillates like
sound in an organ pipe the team observed
muska molecular cloud about 570 light
years from Earth that appears as an
elongated filament using Europe's
Herschel Space Telescope around the
denser filament there appear to be
striations in the guest the astronomers
have suspected might be caused by waves
propagating through the cloud by
analyzing the spacing of the striations
researchers showed that they are caused
by oscillations of the cloud at resonant
frequencies known as normal modes by
modeling such modes and clouds of
various shapes they found that Musca is
not a filament but a sheet viewed
edge-on and could calculate its size the
team hopes that this technique could be
used to study many other clouds and so
shed light on how these stellar
nurseries produce their young
[Music]